[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها هذا المساء
بعد تبادل الزياره مؤخرا هل اصبح فتح
سفرتين السعوديه والايرانيه قاب قوسين او
ادنى وما هي انعكاسات هذا التقارب على
المنطقه
بعد زياره وفدين سعودي وعماني لصنعاء
ولقاء الحوثيين هل اصبحنا على ابواب حل
سياسي شاملا يتضمن تهدئه والتفاوض لتاسيس
شكل الدوله
وتبادل السفراء خطوه جديده للتقارب بين
مصر وتركيا ما اثرها على تنظيم الاخوان
وكذلك على الملفات العالقه بين البلدين
وخاصه ليبيا وغاز المتوسط
[موسيقى]
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول ما توصف
بانها اشارات وتفاؤل تستمر في طريق
المصالحه السعوديه الايرانيه والتي راعتها
الصين في العاشر من الشهر الماضي فالبدء
في تنفيذ الاتفاق الثلاثي الذي وقعته
الدولتان برعايه الصين قد تم لاعاده
العلاقات المقطوعه منذ العام 2016 وفق
وكاله الانباء السعودية ومن المقرر ان
يزور وفد فني ايراني سعوديه هذا الاسبوع
للتجهيز لاعاده فتح السفاره الايرانيه في
الرياض بينما زار وفد دبلوماسيون سعوديون
ايران لمناقشه اليات اعاده افتتاح سفارات
المملكه في طهران والقنصليه العامه في
مشهد بحسب وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه هذه هي
اول زياره رسميه يقوم بها مسؤولون سعوديون
لايران منذ سبعه سنوات وبعد يومين من لقاء
وزيره خارجيه البلدين في بكين هذا وكان
تعهد وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان
ونظيره الايراني حسين امير عبد الهيان
تعهد بالعمل من اجل استثباب الامن
والاستقرار في منطقه الخليج وليس الخليج
فقط فوفق مراقبين فان ايجابيات الاتفاق من
شانها تجنيب منطقه الشرق الاوسط الكثير من
الازمات السياسيه والامنيه
حراك سياسي قوي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المتوتره على كثير من الجبهات تقوده
السعوديه والدول الكبرى في المنطقه في
مسعا لاطفاء كثير من الحرائق التي ظلت
مشتعله لسنوات
عاد الضوء الى طاولات الحوار بدءا بتهدئه
التوتر بين عدد من دول المنطقه وتركيه
مرورا بلقاءات بين القيادات السياسيه
وانتهاء بالاتفاق مع انقره على ايجاد سبل
لحل الملفات او تهدئه حده الصراع في سوريا
وليبيا
العاشر من مارس شهد ايضا ولاده لاتفاق بين
السعوديه وايران برعايه صينيه بعد قطيعه
امتدت لنحو سبع سنوات اعطت املا بظهور
نتائج ايجابيه على ملفات عده بالمنطقه
كسوريا والعراق ولبنان واليمن الخطوه
الاخيره في سلسله التهدئه جاءت من اليمن
بعد زياره وفدي السعوديه وعمان لصنعاء
ولقائهما بقياده الحوثيين وبحث الوصول الى
الحل السياسي عبر عده مراحل يؤمل منها
اعاده الاستقرار الى اليمن بعد ثمان سنوات
من الحرب الدائره هناك
المسارات الدبلوماسيه التي انتهجتها دول
المنطقه صنعت تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سم
الاستقرار وتغليب المصالح الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه على الصراع السياسي والعسكري
ولقيت اشاده دوليه واماميه
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من الرياض جسر
الجاسر الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك من واشنطن
الدكتور حسن هاشميان الباحث فشان الايراني
اهلا بكم ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من الرياض معك استاذ جاسر في الواقع منذ
الاعلان عن الاتفاق الذي وصفه مراقبون
بتاريخي في العاشر من مارس الماضي بنيه
تطبيع العلاقات بين السعوديه وايران بدات
شيئا فشيئا مع مرور الايام تتوضح كيفيه
العمل على التنفيذ بعض هذه النقاط اخر هذه
النقاط هي العمل على اعاده فتح السفارات
وهناك ترتيبات واجراءات جاريه في هذا
الاطار هذه الخطوه استاذ جاسر ما الذي
يمكن ان تمثل في اطار اعاده العلاقات بين
الطرفين
مساء الخير اهلا بك وفقا الاتفاق بكين
يبدو ان الخطوات تتحقق بتسارع عالي جدا
وان هناك حتى الان على الاقل بشكل واضح
استجابه ايرانيه واضحه لكل المتطلبات
السعوديه وتعمل على تنفيذها ولذلك نجد
وهذه رغبه واضحه قويه ايضا هذا التسارع في
العمليه مهم جدا لانه فعلا يؤكد انه نحن
نضيف الطريق الصحيح اليوم مثلا يعني زياره
السفير محمد الجابري الى صنعاء والاقامه
هذه خطوه مهمه جدا هذه لم تكن تحدث لولا
الرساله مباشره من طهران صحيح ان الحضور
الوفد العماني هو جزء من الشراكه هو فريق
عمل المشترك لكن الرساله القويه الخطوه
الاولى اللي هي حددتها المملكه سابقا
بشهرين لبدء العلاقات
هي في ملفين ذكرتهم سابقين يجب ان نتحدث
في ملف اليمني وملف الخلايا الارهابيه
والجماعات الارهابيه التي تحطون ايران
المؤشرات الاولى ايجابيه ونمضي في الطريق
الصحيح ويبدو انه عمليه فتح السفارات ايضا
ستكون اسرع من اتوقع ربما قبل عشره ابريل
اللي هو التاريخ النهائي هذه المسارات
واضح ان هناك نيه واضحه حتى الان في هذا
المسار لتحقيق الاستقرار والعمل عليه
مشترك والطلبات وايضا لا ننسى دور الضامن
الصيني في تحقيق هذه المعادله او في الضغط
على ايران في هذا الجانب اذا هناك عمليه
متحركه كامله وخطواته متسارعه لم يذهب
محمد الجابر الى صنعاء لمجرد السلام او
لبداء عمليه التفاوض تبادل الاسره لا هو
ذهب بروايه محدده لعمليه عقد لقاءات بين
الاطراف اليمنيه تؤسس الى حل سياسي كامل
هذا موضوع الثاني على فكره هذا الموضوع
بانورام
سنخص عشنا في ملف بانوراما الثاني وسنتحدث
عن اليمن لانك تعلم بان هذا الموضوع
بالتحديد يتحمل نقاش طويل وعميق وفي نقاط
عديده يجب ان تناقش ولكن في موضوع اعاده
العمل على ترتيب فتح السفارات حضرتك قلت
بانه هناك خطوات متسارعه قرات بان هناك
حسن النيه من الطرفين وتطبيق محاوله
لتطبيق هذه البنود من الطرفين اسمح لي ان
انقل هذه النقطه للدكتور هاشميان دكتور هل
ترك ضيفي بانه تسارع الخطوات ينبئ او على
الاقل يشير الى ان هناك عمل سبق هذا
الاتفاق المعلن في العاشر من مارس
وبالتالي هناك اتفاقات مبدئيه وفي هذه
المرحله نحن نتابع كيفيه التنفيذ لا اكثر
نعم تحيه لكم ونضيف الكريم ومشاهدين
البرنامج انا اعتقد تفاصيل هي ستكون جدا
مهمه وكما يقولون الشيطان يكمن في
التفاصيل ولذلك انا اعتقد ان النظام
الايراني الان هو مصطل للدخول في هذه
القضيه بهذه الشيك هناك ضغوطات داخليه
الوضع الداخلي متفجر ازمه نوويه واضحه مع
العالم وايضا هناك تدخله في الحرب
الاوكرانيه واضحه ولذلك هناك ضغوط اوروبيه
اكثر من ذلك
النموذج الذي يتبعه النظام الايراني هو
نموذج صيني روسي والان نرى الصين والروس
تتسارع في حسن العلاقات مع الدول الخليج
العربيه دكتور صحيح ولكن حضرتك اكدت على
ان الشيطانيه في التف اصيل وقلت يعني
وكانك تشير الى
انتظار المشهد مستقبلا للتاكد من نيه
ايران من حضرتك طيب ما التفاصيل التي يمكن
ان تعطل مسار هذه العوده
يعني كل هذه الاسباب التي طرحتها هذه
تقول لنا ان النظام الايراني يتغير
تكتيكيه ولكن هل يتغير استراتيجيا لو
نظرنا هو الموضوع اليمني جدا مهم مهم
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه ومهم للعالم
وهناك اولويه جدا كبيره ولكن هل هذا
النظام يقبل بتطبيق غراره
هل يقبل بتطبيق المبادره الخليجيه هل يقبل
في ان الحوثيين يدخلوا في مسار سياسي
يتعاملون مع اخوتهم الاخرين في اليمن انا
استبعد ذلك ان الحوسي سينزع السلاح ويبتعد
عن الطريق
ولكن يبدو بان الملف اليمني يلقي بظله
وبقوه
على
مجمل او مختلف هذه النقاط سنعود لذلك
لاحقا ولكن اسمحوا لي ان نتحدث عن نقطه
اتت في هذا الاتفاق وتحدث بخصوصها
المسؤولون من الجانبين وهي نقطه يثبت
السلاف المنطقه استاذ جاسر هل تعتقد بان
بالبدء بعوده عمل السفارات هي خطوه اوليه
لتثبيت دائم لسلاف المنطقه
وتاخذ فيها وفي مسارات مختلفه ولا تخضى
لكن اليمن نعلم جميعا انه ما يحدث اليمن
هو باراده ورغبه قرار ايران ايران لا تملك
الان مقومات للتاثير في اليمن بشكل كبير
الجماعه الحوثي موجوده لكن لا تملك القدره
على ارسال الاسلحه كما كانت تفعل سابقا
سدت في وجهه كثير من الابواب واضافه الى
مشاكل التي تعانيها فهي حريص الوصول لهذا
تقول المملكه تعرف ذلك وتراهن عليه وتدفع
به ولذلك متوقع قريبا ان يكون هناك خطوات
اخرى نشهدها من الجانب الايراني لتاكيد
هذه النقطه وانها ستعمل على تحقيق
الاستقرار طبعا حنا نقول الاتفاق تم
برعايه خمني وبالتالي ما دام خمني عايش
فاتوقع انه يستمر الوضع على ما هو عليه
والانتفاضات من الممكن جدا حدوث مناوشات
مختلفه لانه يعني من حاله حفظ ماء الوجه
سواء في اليمن او في مناطق اخرى لانه لم
يتم لان هناك الرساله انه هذا القبول هو
قبول وفق الاراده السعوديه لتحق المنطقه
والنيران لا خيرات اليه قد تحدث بعض
الممارسات او النشاطات التي تو بشكل ما ان
نحن لا لازمنا انه التفاوض معين لكن هذه
لا تؤثر المملكه تطلع الى استقرار دائم
وتدفع بايران الى ذلك وحاله حللت هذا
الملفات ودخول السفارات هي خطوه اولى ليست
خطوه هي حتى تبادل السفراء لا يمثل على ما
نهائيه على استقرار هو يمثل على مرحله
اخرى فقط هناك خطوات اخرى لابد تتحقق ويتم
العمل عليها وقبل ان نصل الى النشاط
المظله الامنه دائما في كل العلاقات
الحقيقيه بين البلدان الاستثمار التجاري
والاقتصادي بين البلدين اذا بدات عمليه
تدفق الاستثمارات بين البلدين سنقول نعم
دخلنا في يعني بدايه خرجنا من النفق
المظلم لكن اليوم نحن كمن يمشي معه كشاف
يضيع المنطقه في نفق لكنه لا يريد نهايه
النفق يريد ما خطوات
هذا الكلام صحيح ولكن حضرتك ترى بانه
الصلاه في المنطقه يمر باليمن وكنت اشرت
الى انه هذا الملف الثاني ولكن طالما
اتفقت على اهميه هذا الملف خلينا نكمل هذا
الجزء
بالملف اليمني او ما تبقى في هذا الجزء
دكتور هاشميان قررت واكدت كذلك منذ قليل
على ان مفتاح السلام في المنطقه يمر
باليمن وعلى ان اليمن سيكون الاختبار
الحقيقي
لبلوغ
مهله او على الاقل بلوغ مرحله سلامه في
المنطقه او لا لماذا هذا الملف يبدو مهما
جدا ليس فقط للطرفين ولكن كذلك للمنطقه
هذا الملف هو ملف جدا مهم من حيث المواضيع
الامنيه الحوثيين طبعا هددوا امن المنطقه
هددوا امن
الطريق البحري في باب المانجا ولذلك ليس
فقط تهديدا لدول الجوار بل تهديدا للعالم
وتهديدا
طرق المائيه الموجوده في العالم ولذلك
كلها تنظر حضرتك بانه اختبار حقيقي لايران
اختبار حقيقي لايران هناك سبب جدا مهم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لا يهمها من
يحكم اليمن يهمها الاستقرار ويهمه الامن
في هذه البلد وهم ان لا توجد هناك تهديدات
للدول الجوار ولكن هناك فرق بين المملكه
العربيه السعوديه والنظام الايراني النظام
الايراني يهمه فقط ان الحوثي يحكم في
اليمن وليس لديه اي بديل اخر ولذلك يعمل
كل شيء من اجل هذا الهدف ان الحوثي بسلاحه
وبمجموعاته يبغى حاكما في اليمن هناك
مساله مهمه يجب ان نطرحها هنا ان النظام
الايراني وهي نقطه ايجابيه النظام
الايراني لا يمكن الرجوع عن الطريق الذي
طرحته الصين بهذه المبادره وهذه المصالحه
هذه نقطه المهم ولكن النقطه السلبيه ان
النظام الايراني يعمل تكتيكات امام الصين
او امام الدول الاخرى او امام الدول
الخليجيه وليس هناك تغيير في الاستراتيجيه
نحن كيرانيين نعرف خامنا جيدا لم يلتزم
بكلامه يوم ولم يلتزم بسياسته في يوم
دائما يغير السياسات ويغير كلامه ويغير
تصريحاته من اجل مصالحه ومن اجل ان ينفذ
الاجنده التي يريدها ولذلك نحن لا نؤمن
بما يقوله خامني وبما يطرحه في هذه
المبادره المطروحه الان في المصالحه ولكن
الان النظام الايراني يحتاج الى مد الجسور
الى الجوار العربي انظروا في العالم مثل
دوله مثل كوريا الشماليه وهي دوله متمرده
على كل العالم ولكن هذه الدوله المتمرده
تحت الى الجوار الصيني حتى تتنفس لذلك هذا
النظام يحتاج الى الجوار العربي وخاصه
الدول الخليجيه حتى ليحقق استقراره كذلك
ويحقق ازدهاره وهذا ما قاله مسؤولين اختم
معك يا استاذ جاسر ماذا عن الجانب السعودي
في هذا الاطار متى بدات المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تفكر بطريقه فعليه في تغيير
منهجها الامني تجاه الحرف اليمن البعض
يقول بان استهداف ارامكو في 2019 والرد
الامريكي الباهت هو الذي دفع المملكه الى
اعاده ترتيب بعض التفاصيل هل هذا دقيق
لا اعتقد احنا نتكلم على مؤشرات لكن من
2016 والمملكه تؤكد على ضروره تحقيق
الاستقرار في اليمن ومن قبل ذلك اكدت على
ان الحوثي مكون يمني شرط ان يعمل ضمن
الرؤيه اليمنيه لم المملكه لم تحارب
الحوثي لانه يعني تختلف معه تختلف تريد ان
يكون في احد الاطراف اليمنيه هذه مساله
واضحه وذكرت كثيرا في تصريحات المسؤولين
السعوديين في على مختلف المستويات ابدا لم
يكن هذه النقطه مهمه جدا انه لا صراع عمل
حوثي صراعنه نعرف اليوم مثلا نعود الى
نقطه اللقاء السفير محمد يعني ايران لا
ايران لا تعترف انها ترى على الحوثي لكننا
نعرف جميعا من الداخل ان هذا ان هذا
التحرك تم باراده ايرانيه وبالتالي نحن
نتعامل الان مع ذراعي ايرانيه ظاهره ولكن
المحرك العرائس والخلف في طهران غير ظاهر
فالصوره الصوره بسيطه واستحقق هذه المساله
شكر من الرياض جسر جاسر كتب الصحفي ومن
واشنطن الدكتور حسن هاشميان الباحث
فشان الايراني شكرا لكما
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات